Three.
Two we need like a digital counter.
Three,
two,
one.
Whew.
If you're going to drink that,
Andrew,
be very careful.
It's 270 milligrams of caffeine.
That Ooh,
right.
That'd be donated.
That allowed.
You can have that.
Brendan drank one of those yesterday and
a pot of coffee and have a cup of coffee
and then on top of that he drank a,
what'd he have?
Something?
A venti with a shot of espresso in it
from starbucks with all cha all doing it
while he was fasting.
So a halfway into the podcast,
he starts hurling,
runs into the bathroom,
throws up,
then it comes back and then throws up in
a bucket at the end of the podcast.
Literally didn't,
didn't make it out of the room
so they could have had a heated seat if
you had to take a shit.
Yeah,
we have a heat instead of 200 7,270
milligrams.
Yeah.
Caveman coffee.
Nitrogenated it's basically like
espresso with nitrogen in it.
It's good stuff.
You get used to it.
Good.
I'll take it before bed.
Yeah,
that's a good move.
You'll have some weird dreams.
All right.
Take Express will before I go to bed.
Andrew,
I'm not used to this clean shaven,
Andrew.
Yeah,
like a different human.
You could sneak up on people.
That's the point,
man.
My daughter's about,
oh,
about a year ago,
said they had enough of the beard so it
had to go.
Oh,
when I was a,
well when my daughter was one,
a friend of mine died and we on the
Internet,
we'd all had this guy,
Evan Tanner,
who is a former UFC champion.
And we had decided that we were all
gonna grow beards for him cause he had
this crazy giant beard.
And so a bunch of us on the Internet did
it.
And I just grew this fucking werewolf
beard.
And then it got to a point where I was
like,
you know,
it was time was up.
I was going to shave it off.
And my daughter had no idea what I
really looked like.
So I shaved my face and she started
screaming.
She thought it was somebody else and she
started crying and I'm like,
touch it.
This is,
this is my normal face.
And then she's confused.
She's like,
I know that voice.
Like who are you there?
That's what it looks like.
Oh Nice.
That's a sand a half with my boys.
They were,
they were young too,
like so they had never seen me without
it.
So like they thought you were a stranger
to then you see that that's because
we're on TV.
I trimmed the cheek areas cause it creep
up.
Gq.
Gq Did.
Yeah.
I'm trying to look fresh.
Well I have to admit the fact that after
30 years of not having a beard meeting
you right,
I ended up with that beard and then
started speaking Arabic.
Right out of nowhere.
Out of nowhere.
How weird.
It was more academic to go when you're
lecturing on the lecture circuit
sometimes for,
but for
guy with your experience,
like that kind of beard is a,
it's normal.
Yeah.
I mean guys who have lived your line of
work,
I don't know man.
It's like counter culture,
so anti establishment establishment.
So that's part of it.
You know.
And like anything else you get into,
I don't know.
It felt normal.
Right.
So it was like a,
probably a crutch a little bit and uh,
something that felt right for a long
time.
I don't think it's a crutch,
but I think it's definitely like a mark
of the,
the occupation.
I remember a red tick mark Kinko's book.
Shanko Marchenko I read one of his books
way,
way back in the day.
Rogue Warrior.
Yeah.
And they were talking about guys who had
dress,
they just how they didn't fit in with
like regular military.
Yeah,
no,
totally,
totally like,
uh,
unconventional.
Probably a better way to say it.
You know what I mean?
So not in with authority,
not in with,
you know,
uh,
everybody being the same way,
not down with uniforms,
not down with,
you know,
using name and rank,
we called everybody by their first name,
grew our hair long,
grew beards wrong.
It was just kind of,
uh,
you had to earn that.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So that's part of it.
Like,
Hey,
I earned the right to be able to be
autonomous,
so,
so to speak.
And so that's kind of the,
uh,
some of it.
It is interesting.
You know that that's the,
the,
I mean,
I don't want to make distinctions,
but the baddest motherfuckers in the
military are the ones who dress like,
like just regular savages.
It's something,
there's something odd about that.
Right?
I Dunno man.
There's just a,
like that idea though,
that you have to earn it.
Yeah.
You got to earn it.
And you know,
it's like you get so tired of doing what
you're told and you want to do what you
think you need to do for the job.
You know what I mean?
So like what,
what is it,
how,
how do I see that I need to accomplish
this task,
whatever it is.
And I don't need to be dictated from
somebody who's not going to be there
telling me how to do it.
And so that goes all the way down to
even like,
okay,
well what kind of boots am I going to
wear?
What Kinda,
what Kinda uniform do I need to
accomplish this mission or do these
things?
And I just kind of,
that's the way those guys are.
They're always thinking about,
you know,
not,
not how to,
not how to fall in line man,
but like how can we think differently to
solve problems and,
uh,
you know,
the uniform is just one of those things.
This is very interesting now,
um,
for just,
so this is a standalone podcast so
people don't have to go back and listen
to the first one that we did.
We have Dr. Mark Gordon here,
a good friend of mine and,
um,
Andrew Marr who is the founder of the
warrior angel.
Yeah.
Me and my cofounder.
Me and my brother Adam Mar,
who was also in the army
and we did a podcast a while back,
but for the people that didn't hear,
explain what the Warrior Angels
Foundation is and what you guys do.
Yeah.
Can I get some context first,
Joe?
So we talked about I was special forces
green baret for a better part of a
decade,
you know,
so I would say somebody defined by my
vision of the future.
Uh,
and so that always led me to doing what
I wanted to do in life.
And so,
you know,
special forces,
Spec ops type dudes,
they're in life and death situations
pretty regularly and,
uh,
perform,
otherwise they don't live.
You know what I mean?
And so that was kind of life for the
better part of 10 years being in life
and death situations on a regular basis.
And so going from that,
you know,
uh,
I would say a high performer,
by,
you know,
by every metric to one day after my last
deployment,
uh,
I woke up and I was on 13 different
medications.
You know,
I couldn't remember how to drive home
from the same route that I've been
driving home every day.
Uh,
I was just in chronic pain all the time.
I had these balance issues where I
couldn't walk in a straight line,
uh,
blurry vision would go into double
vision and I had these horrible migraine
headaches.
So just the ability to bring that way
and then,
uh,
started to have become depressed.
And this was like,
uh,
this was just mind boggling to me
because I was living,
I thought my life's purpose,
right?
Doing the job I wanted to do with the
people I wanted to be with Mary,
to the woman of my dreams,
had the family that we always wanted.
But yet here I am,
I have all these physical problems.
Now I'm starting to be depressed and I
don't have a reason to be depressed.
And then I started having panic attacks
in public,
in our weight room at home,
in front of my kids,
you know,
like just breaking down crying and not
knowing why and not being able to do
anything about it.
And,
uh,
and then I started to have,
you know,
and that was again,
like my,
the structure of reality.
It was fracturing around me.
And,
uh,
I,
I didn't know why or what was going on,
you know,
and the first thing he can think to do
and something like that was to drink.
I was like,
I gotta I gotta stop this and I don't,
I don't know what to do.
Uh,
I think I have some screws loose or
what's going on,
but all I know is this is so disastrous.
Maybe if I just drank,
I can,
I can put the,
put the brakes on this a little bit and
uh,
and,
and things just continued to get worse
and then my behavior just continue to
skyrocket out of control.
And it wasn't like I was making
conscious decisions to be fucked up.
Uh,
like I'm driving,
I'm drinking and driving on a regular
basis and I never even crossed my mind.
Like,
that was a wrong thing to do.
It was just like,
hey man,
I can't function unless I drink and I
got to drive.
So that's what we're going to do,
you know?
And then,
uh,
start producing just horrible effects on
my family with that line of behavior.
And it got to the point and,
and as a special forces operator,
man,
all you want to do is operate.
All you want to do is be on the team and
go and do the things that we signed up
to do.
It didn't have any problem with that or
it wasn't like,
Oh,
you know,
all these combat scenarios are weighing
on me and it's been too much and,
and I just can't handle it.
Like,
that's the only thing I felt comfortable
doing and wanted to get back to it.
And,
uh,
but again,
like I'd never had any of these symptoms
before.
So life is just spiraling out of control
and not sleeping and everything else.
And so finally,
you know,
you sit on it until you can't sit on any
longer.
And it got to the point where I was
like,
I'm not only am I a detriment to myself
and probably society,
like I can't go out and operate right
now,
like these guys can depend on me.
And so at that point I was like,
I gotta raise my hand and I got to get
some help.
And,
um,
you know,
that well intended people,
eh,
wanted to offer as much help and find
the answers as they possibly could.
But again,
all that got me was 13 different
medications and,
uh,
it was told,
hey,
you've had so many head injuries,
you can't afford to take another blow to
the head.
And this is probably going to be the new
you.
You're going to be on these medications,
take a pen and a pad everywhere you go.
And,
um,
and learn how to live within these new
parameters and schedule out your meds
and this is,
this is going to be that.
And so it was a medical retirement.
It got so bad,
Joe,
that my wife was nine months pregnant
with our fifth child and she had to ask
me,
Hey Andrew,
can you keep your drinking down today in
case I go into labor so I don't have to
drive myself to the hospital,
you know,
so that's all bad it was getting.
And that wasn't enough to stop me.
And so she actually,
our son had a,
uh,
genetic,
lymphatic malformation,
his neck,
and he got sick.
He's like 13 months old and it got
infected and it blew up to like the size
of a softball.
And this is when she's nine months
pregnant.
So we have to take him to the emergency
room.
And my calf had been killing me for
about three days at this point.
Uh,
I didn't think anything of it.
I just wrote it off.
But we're in there in the emergency
room,
like he's having trouble breathing.
It's,
it's bad like a softball.
And his neck.
Well,
he turns out he has to go into emergency
surgery and then becky goes into labor.
Um,
so he's up on like the fifth floor
getting emergency surgery.
Becky's given labor to our youngest son
on the second floor.
So I'm going back and forth between the
fifth floor on the second floor.
And I'm like dragging my leg at this
point cause it just stopped working.
Um,
but you know,
I was all in and refuse any care till I
get these two taken care of.
Well,
we get Jason out of surgery.
Uh,
you know,
he's on the road to recovery,
get down for the birth.
Uh,
we have our son Joe,
Joe,
he's good to go.
And then it turns out,
uh,
they finally rushed me to imaging and I
have a blood clot in my leg and it's
broken off into both long.
So now I have a bilateral pulmonary
embolisms and at this point they're
like,
hey man,
like we have a very small window here.
This is very high mortality rate.
And A,
I'm like laughing at them because like,
you know,
I was drunk at the time.
No bullshit.
And I'm like,
you guys think this is going to kill me,
get in line.
This isn't the vis a long line of
offenders here that,
that I want a shot at that.
But um,
so anyway,
so I'm sitting there in the hospital
room and I'm just wondering and waiting
for somebody to come explain to me like
how life has spiraled out of control
like this.
And like somebody's going to say,
hey,
this is a reason that you have these
blood clots.
You know,
here's what's going on with your head
and all these things.
And it just,
it never happens.
And I remember like,
I got to go down and visit my son,
uh,
who was,
in emergency recovery and I was there at
his hospital bed and,
uh,
I had a bottle of whiskey or airplane
bottle of whiskey and I popped the last
pain pill I ever took and I shot down
the whiskey.
That was just normal 24,
seven.
How I operated at that time,
tried to just to cope and a,
I had this epiphany,
you know,
that hey,
if I continue on this same track and I
continue to just wholesale buy,
everything in the medical system is,
is telling me it's going to kill me and
it's going to ruin everything that I
love so I can stay on that route or I
can decide to act and to change what I
don't like.
And at that point it was everything.
And so I made the promise to my son
right then and there that I was going to
do some things.
One,
I was going to get off all medication
and I was going to return to the man of
my pre-injury status too.
I was going to find a way to heal
myself.
And then three,
I was going to turn around and do that
same thing for somebody else.
And so right then and there and the
hospital's bed,
and I mean this is the honest to God,
true story.
I said,
I don't care how,
I don't know how,
but I've had enough.
I've had enough of people telling me
that my life is over.
And at that time,
you know,
my identity was in special forces and
that was taken away because of the
medical injuries.
And I said,
I don't care anymore.
I'm still a husband.
I'm still a father and I'm going to get
better.
And that was enough to pull me out of
there,
out of that negative spiral that I was
in.
And to start being proactive again and
start being defined by a vision of the
future.
And my vision of the future was just
what I said.
And I didn't know it was going to lead
to where we're at today,
but that was the catalyst.
And so I started going and looking for
alternative therapies and it turned out
like the government didn't want to pay
for anything that wasn't covered by
their insurance.
Well,
that's fine.
I'll charge it a max it on credit cards.
That's fine.
I'll get more credit cards.
I don't care.
I don't care if it's $1 million,
I will get the money and I will get
better and I will solve this problem.
And,
uh,
then I started getting objective about
it and that was like,
you know,
talking to everybody out there who's
having head problems like,
hey,
what's working for you guys?
And I got real interested in why did
some things work for some people and
then not work for others,
you know,
precursor and meeting mark.
But I'm starting to get really
scientific minded or you know,
one objective data to be able to support
things.
And so there's all this,
these other treatment modalities out
there and I did every single one of them
and some of them were little bit of a
benefit in the short term.
Some of them,
you know,
reversed or made symptoms worse.
Um,
but it was leading to that that we got
some,
some publicity out of it.
Mark read about it and just contacted me
and he didn't know anything else about
me at that point,
but he said,
hey,
you know,
we've been treating Tbi for a number of
years now here's my credentials,
here's the background story on it.
Here's some media that I had done and it
was a podcast that you guys had done a
couple back with.
Uh,
when,
uh,
he had matt Gaza Neon and I'm listening
to Matt tell a story.
And for the first time ever through
hearing him,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
this isn't specific to me.
Like I got so wrapped up in myself like
I thought like the whole world's on
pause and this is,
this is this my problem.
And I realized,
Oh my God,
this is a much bigger problem that has
wide reaching a repercussion is that
doesn't just deal with me specifically.
And so as I'm hearing matt talk about
all the problems that he's having,
it's like he's like tall telling my
story to the teeth and then I hear mark
say,
well,
not only that,
but we can identify,
uh,
an underlying condition for all of the
things that we were just talking about.
And we can measure it objectively.
And like,
that just blew my mind.
Cause I was like,
here I am on 13 medications.
And there wasn't one objective
measurement where somebody said,
let's put them on antidepressant
depressant.
Let's put him on another antidepressant.
Let's put him on anti anxiety.
I was like,
there was nothing objective about that.
wait a minute.
So they're not,
there was nothing you were saying there
was nothing.
They were measuring subjective as
there's a level of this that we need to
move up.
There's a level of that we need to,
right.
Yeah.
Based off the symptoms and the
complaints I had,
it was just throwing darts.
It's like I said,
13 medications from a person who never
had any issue before
and to all the guys that have served
that have gone through this kind of
thing and not just guys that have
served,
but also when you're dealing with Tbi.
We're talking about athletes,
we're talking about former fighters.
Yeah.
A lot of guys that have been in contact
with on a regular basis have these
issues and what mark has done,
which has been just phenomenal,
was open up a new door for treatment to
these people.
And I have talked to so many people and
I've been in contact with so many people
that heard about you through the podcast
that we've done together and heard about
your work and have gone on to completely
remove these medications.
Correct.
You know,
that's a problem in psychiatry is there
are no real biological markers.
They're trying to use a radiographic
studies like Spec Scans,
Mris,
pet scans,
and what have you as rationale for
starting people on medication.
But there's absolutely,
you know,
in the biomarker or the biomarker panel
that we have,
there's a direct correlation between
someone having had a head trauma re
regardless of it was mild or a blast
trauma like Andrew had or a slip and
fall or someone coming up and hitting
you behind the headboard,
mma or boxers or Muay tight and there's
absolutely zero that they use to
regulate what they're doing.
It says,
okay,
today's Thursday,
let's try this drug,
or this is Friday or else this month
we're giving you this Satchel of meds.
As many of the vets have come up and
told me,
depending upon the day of the week
dictated what groupings of medications
they were given what,
but let's break it down for people.
What do you feel is the underlying cause
of all this?
It's related to Tbi.
Okay,
great question.
And the answer is number one from the
head trauma,
it elicits chemical changes in the brain
that we call inflammation.
And this inflammation leads to
disruption of chemical processes.
It's like,
you know,
the old alkaline batteries or the car
batteries where we used to put distilled
water into it.
Well,
if you put coca cola in it,
it totally changes the ability of
electrons to be conducted just like in
the brain.
So the chemistry of the brain is altered
by the inflammation and it starts
shutting down systems so that the nerves
in left side of the brain can't talk to
the right side,
or the frontal lobe of the brain can
talk to the temporal lobe of the brain.
So you have disruption of,
um,
executive function,
which is your ability to make correct
decisions about things right and wrong.
Why do we have over a million veterans
incarcerated?
That's because they can't make the right
correct decisions about how to respond
to an innocuous,
uh,
you know,
approach by an individual that they
don't know and they respond by,
uh,
assault or with physical or anger or a
yelling at people and that leads him
into jail or into incarceration.
So anyway,
the inflammation leads to hormonal
deficiencies in the brain.
And what we've found is that there's,
since 1986,
Dr Baylew out of Paris found that we
have enzyme systems that take
cholesterol and convert it into hormones
that actuate and regulate our brain
function from schizophrenia to als,
to Parkinson's disease,
to bipolar,
to all the different disorders.
There was a recent article that I sent
out to our journal Group and Andrew's in
it,
and it was about management event,
thigh of neuroinflammation,
brain inflammation to treat psychiatric
diseases.
And in the past six months,
we've been starting to see a lot of
articles talking specifically about
inflammation,
creating all these things that we're
trying to treat with medications that
are ineffective.
Uh,
last month,
uh,
had a class in,
Arizona and I presented a group of
articles and one of the key articles was
the fact that they found people with
atypical depression.
That's depression that doesn't respond
to traditional medication.
So you're on whole bunch 13 medications
and you're still depressed.
So they found in 61% of these people who
were still depressed with atypical
depression,
that they had growth hormone deficiency.
And then when they replaced the growth
hormone within one to two months,
their depression disappeared.
And they had some beneficial side
effects.
They slept better,
they had more mental energy,
they were socially more adaptable,
and they're reactive scores that
creates,
you know,
an assault situation.
They were calm,
someone said booted them and they said,
Oh,
who do?
As opposed to getting into their face.
So it's a very clear,
and it's becoming clearer and clearer in
the literature around the world.
Now we've been doing this since 2004 and
the inflammation is really the problem.
So unfortunately there is no specific
medication.
They talk about use of aspirin and
Ibuprofen in things like Alzheimer's
disease,
which is an inflammatory disease.
I know I shared it with you in the past
that if a football player has one major
concussion on the field,
he's 19 times at greater risk of
developing Alzheimer's between 30 and 49
years of age because it's an
inflammatory illness.
It's not,
you know,
genetics by itself.
There are people with genetic
predisposition to it because they
generate this thing called Beta amyloid.
But trauma,
any kind of trauma to the head can
elicit increased production of Beta
amyloid and lead to these problems.
So the,
the traumatic brain injury causes this
inflammation.
And there's a,
there's a process that goes on when the
brain is dealing with this inflammation.
And that's what's disrupting all of
these normal functions.
Executive functions.
Absolutely.
And you know,
we have different,
um,
relay centers in our brain that regulate
whether or not you're going to be calm
or you going to be hyper,
have anxiety.
One of the products that we use 100%
natural,
about 80% of our treatment is all
natural products with 10 to 20% being
pharmaceutical products,
but no psychotropic or brain altering
medications slugging.
What,
what kind of products do you use?
Training alone,
pregnenolone.
There's 6,160 articles talking about its
beneficial effect on anxiety.
So we have people who come in on a
multitude of anxiety medications within
three months.
They're off all their medication.
They're alone.
Pregnenolone is called the mother of all
hormones.
It's the precursor.
It comes right off of cholesterol.
The first comp,
uh,
changed cholesterol becomes
pregnenolone,
which goes down one pathway to become
testosterone and then down another
pathway to become cortisol,
which is the anti inflammatory product.
So we get benefits of,
you know,
antiinflammatory effect by having
pregnenolone.
But if you're on any kind of stat and
drug that decreases the availability of
cholesterol in the brain or the body,
you lose.
I have heard nothing but bad things
about staten drugs.
Don't get me going.
I want to get you going because there's
so many people that have this very
meager understanding of cholesterol and
a understanding of like what is the
difference between having a,
you know,
high cholesterol,
low cholesterol,
what,
you know,
what is,
what's healthy,
what's not healthy?
What's your cholesterol mark?
My cholesterol is 350.
My ldl is,
and it should be according to the
present standards,
less than 200.
My ldl cholesterol is two 73 my uh,
which is the ldl is the lousy kind and
Hdl,
which is the happy to have the healthy
one is like 23 to 40.
How did the numbers change over time?
They're all saying no for the state,
for the standard.
Oh,
of where they used to measure from the
70s till now in my infancy in medicine,
uh,
back in the late eighties,
it was 349 and then went to 329 then two
79 then to 49 to 29 in less than 200
now.
And we would expect our nutrition is
changing the quality of foods that we
eat.
And the fact that we have since 1986
staten drugs,
which are $36 billion a year,
we would anticipate that the rate of
cardiovascular disease should be diving,
getting lower.
It's not,
it's going up.
So what does it tell us?
It tells us like a Smithkline Beecham us
study that was done.
50% of all heart attacks happen in
people with normal or low levels of
cholesterol.
So the question is then what's causing
it?
Well,
it turns out inflammation.
You start looking at inflammatory
chemistry.
We,
there's a group of um,
inflammatory markers that we have a
which sdl,
dl,
homocysteine LP,
little a.
So a whole group of them that can
predict better than cholesterol,
your risk for heart disease.
And what we do in the offices,
we have a biomarker panel for cardiac
inflammation.
Person comes in,
they've got a history of elevated
cholesterol.
One of my closest buddies,
Keith,
uh,
x fighter pilot,
his clusteral one 41 50 my cholesterol
303 50 we went and had an ultra fast ct
scan that looks at the heart and his
calcium score was greater than 2000
which if it's a hundred or less as good
grade than 400 horrible.
Mine was zero and I had cholesterol that
was three times his.
So after he had his open heart surgery
and his New v arteries put in,
we went and had this panel called an lp
six my cholesterol sky high,
but all these inflammatory markers,
low and keith situation,
his inflammatory markers were sky high
even though his cholesterol was very
low.
Yeah,
there's a simplistic understanding of
what what's causing these issues and
people peg it on cholesterol and you
hear it so often,
so many times,
and you're like,
boy,
how do I even begin having this
conversation with people?
I would like to,
if anybody's listening and you want to
really get into this,
a doctor Rhonda Patrick went pretty deep
on it in the last podcast that we did
and the newly found connections between
refined sugars and refined carbohydrates
and saturated fats.
The combination of the two seems to be a
gigantic issue where a saturated fats on
their own are not an issue.
The small particle versus large particle
Ldl,
small particles are the dangerous ones,
right?
Stld is dangerous,
but it's at greater risk when you have
an enzyme called a pla two in the blood,
which causes the stld.
L does small density Ldl to fracture
into two parts that cause the immune
system to be called in and once the
immune system
gets there,
it creates all this inflammation and
there's something that happens with ldl.
When you combine it with a refined
sugars that's extremely bad for you.
It makes it worse.
Yeah,
extremely bad sugars,
corn syrup,
things that people are drinking sodas
and cake and bullshit,
all the refined bread and we products.
All that stuff is fucking terrible for
you.
Well,
it's just adding more inflammation on
top of it.
And it's being conflated with saturated
fats and with cholesterol.
And it's,
it's not what the issue is.
Correct.
So think about if you have a brain
injury and you're eating like that,
you know what I mean?
Just like your [inaudible] on a fire and
having no idea about it.
Like that's the issue that we face a lot
of times.
So there's,
there's the inflammation response and
then there's also the,
the issues with the pituitary gland and
the hormonal deficiencies.
Well,
it's,
it's not only the two Terry Glen,
which generates the,
uh,
signals to the thyroid gland,
testicles at the ovaries to make their
hormones are the adrenal glands,
but it's the fact that the,
um,
we call them glial cells,
which are astrocytes and neuro cells,
which generate their own hormones.
And it turns out that the hormones
produced a below the neck have a genomic
effect on the body,
which is slow.
It means it turns on genetic switches to
do things.
But the hormones produced in the brain
called the neuro steroids.
They have the immediate effect because
they influence the membranes of neurons
to do things.
So our ability to be rational because
you're taking different parts of the
brain and they're all working in unison
as opposed to having this section that
deals with,
you know how you respond to someone
talking in a high voice to you or
pointing a gun at you or pointing at
Pencil at you so you lose that
integration of the different parts of
the brain.
That's what each of the lobes is
responsible for is how we integrate
signals coming in that the whole thing
is so fascinating because it seems like
there's so much to understand and for,
for the average person that goes to your
general practitioner and the General
Practitioner says,
Oh,
I've got high cholesterol.
You need to be on a stat and drug,
and then you find out about all this.
People get extremely angry.
I've talked to so many people that were
on staten drugs and suffered all sorts
of health consequences because of that
and then realize,
oh,
what about cutting all the fucking sugar
out of my diet?
What about doing,
doing all this stuff that has been shown
in all these more recent studies to have
a significant effect?
Absolutely.
It's unfortunate that when science comes
out and it's really good science that it
takes another 20 to 30 years before it
gets into the medical community.
And there's no obligation for your
general practitioner to be up on this
dot.
No,
absolutely not.
Because it's status quo and it's
changing constantly.
Yes,
and that's what has me and frustrated
state all the time is because of the
science that's been sitting on the
bench.
What I do,
what I've been told I do is called
translational medicine,
where I take the research that's on the
bench that's already been done and I
look at it in large groups and then
applied into the clinical practice.
And that's how we've had our success is
we've got us,
we've taken the stuff that's sitting
there ready to be used that's not being
used because we're in the paradigm of
don't do anything for 30 years.
I mean every generation a little bit,
something better happens,
but it takes 30 years.
It's incredibly frustrating.
So Andrew,
please go back to how you found out
about mark and what changes you made and
what happened.
[inaudible] yeah.
Well,
um,
cause I've only known you since you've
been happy.
It's been a good ride,
but you know,
if you lower cholesterol mark,
it ruins all the hormonal production.
Correct.
Right.
And,
uh,
so that's not understood.
But so,
uh,
I mark found me,
I looked into everything.
I was just saying one over,
listen to listen to that research,
did my own research,
found out about the neuroendocrine
system and ran it by my own people.
And so I went and saw an
endocrinologist.
I was still in the army at this time.
And I was saying,
Hey,
do you think that any of these problems
were based off of the,
you know,
hundreds or thousands of explosions that
weave around on a,
on a routine basis?
He's like,
no,
I don't.
I don't think so.
And,
uh,
he was like a,
I was like,
well,
can we test and replace any hormones
that I'm missing?
Because,
I mean at that time we had done some
tests and I knew that I was deficient in
things and he's like,
ah,
I'm going to test you for anabolic
steroids because I think the reason
you're having these problems is you're
abusing anabolic steroids and if you
pass the test and you prove that you're
not on anabolic steroids,
which will take about four to six weeks,
then we'll talk about it.
Replacement Treatment Program.
And I was fucking irate man.
Like I told him that he accused,
you accuse me of being a,
going to him because his levels were so
low.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's like,
I've never seen levels this low unless
somebody was abusing anabolic steroids.
And so you must be abusing antibiotics,
steroids and,
and you're here essentially trying to
score drugs.
Well,
if people don't understand what you're
saying,
um,
when you take antibiotics,
steroids,
your natural testosterone shuts down.
A lot of times when people get off
steroids,
then they'll go to a doctor,
they're natural testosterone to shut
down and they'll go to a doctor to try
to get hormone replacement therapy
because the only way a doctor is going
to give you hormone replacement
therapies if your levels are low.
And so one of the reasons for having low
levels is that you've,
you've put all this exotic in his shit
in there and it's,
you know,
your,
your whole body's all confused.
Yeah.
So thanks for clarifying that mark.
Like I a what?
Who was it like,
hey man,
you think I'm coming in here putting all
this personal stuff on you because I
like,
I like to make things up just cause you
want steroids cause I want steroid
wants,
my life's a disaster and I think this is
funny and I worry that he would you,
you know what I mean?
It happened,
it happened twice.
Joe,
twice back to back.
You understand that there's other issues
that cause your body to have low
testosterone.
That's what's crazy.
So this is what puts to push us in this
direction,
man.
So I was like,
well,
I sat at that point,
I started reading some of the literature
and I was like,
it's not even black.
I mean,
it's not even in the gray area.
This is black and white.
There's like blast trauma can through
inflammation affect the hypothalamus and
the pituitary gland and downregulate all
these hormones.
And so anyways,
so I finally,
I link up with mark in southern
California.
Um,
we run the labs,
but we don't get the results back for
like two or three weeks.
But he gives me a,
what we call it,
provocative testosterone injection,
just to see how I react.
And like up until this point,
man,
like my life has just been a complete
disaster.
I mean,
I've put a gun in my mouth several times
and actually had thought about like,
if this is how life is going to continue
and I continue to have this type of
negative effect on my family,
I think I'll just end it,
man.
You know what I mean?
And,
um,
and I got to the point where I was just
like,
I can't do it for my family alone.
And just kept driving.
So found mark,
mark found me,
got the information and actually is
there to see him in his office in
Encino.
Get that injection.
I'm driving south on the four oh five
I'm in bumper to bumper traffic like two
hours later.
And usually man like me and traffic just
didn't mix.
Um,
and to say that I had a hostile temper
was like the understatement of the year.
And I realized like,
Hey,
I'm all of a sudden I'm cool,
I'm calm,
I'm collected and not having any issues.
I'm like,
Whoa,
I f I don't feel any anxiety.
Like for the last year and a half,
I like it had this fist like coming out
of my stomach man,
like at all times 24,
seven.
It was horrible.
And it was gone.
And I was like,
if this is any taste of what could be,
this is incredible.
And I call my wife and we have a
conversation for like an hour.
And that's the first time that we had
talked more than two minutes in like a
year.
And I didn't just say yes or no because
I just wasn't capable of,
of anything else at that time.
And um,
so fast forward for a few weeks from
there,
you know,
he gets the report back and he's like,
hey man,
you're deficient in everything.
You know,
but we can,
we can fix this.
And so we get on anti-inflammatory
protocol and we replaced,
we replaced the and replenish the
hormones that are deficient or
insufficient and life slowly and surely
started to turn back on little by little
by little,
by little to where I'm at today,
I'm off all medication.
Uh,
you know,
I'm clean,
I'm sober,
uh,
performing as good,
if not better than my pre-injury status.
We startup organization called the
Warrior Angels Foundation to deliver
this same level of healing to other
people who are in the exact same
predicament and situation.
And now I'm excited to say,
man,
three years later we've delivered to
over 200 people with incredible results.
So it meets with the scientific criteria
we can predict,
we can measure and we can replicate.
And now it's not just my story,
it's not just Mac os and he's Tori.
Mark's done this like 1400 times.
We had done it 200 times through our
organization where somebody,
like we did a three year Tbi study
cohort,
we took 58 of a,
of those 200 people,
just the ones that are committed,
attempted suicide,
58 individuals attempted suicide.
We had,
we showed that within three months they,
um,
what was it?
91% had a 50% improvement.
Correct.
So almost everybody had at least a 50%.
This isn't their subjective analysis
improvement.
After one year 90,
uh,
let's see,
73% of that population was off all
medication.
This is unheard of.
And this is people that wanted,
that actually attempted to take their
own life,
I think a minimum of two times in our
study.
So we're,
we're,
we're producing results that have never
been annotated before.
You know what I mean?
And it's through the scientific model
that marks come up with this protocols.
It's unbelievable.
That's on our website.
Uh,
we got,
we got all that research on our website
to check Waf,
tbi.org,
but I got marks Predator as well.
I got mark's presentation.
We got an incredible media page,
a library of all this information that
didn't exist three years ago.
It's now all in one location and all the
stuff that I'm saying here,
please don't take my word for word.
You guys go out and fact check it.
And I can't tell you how many guys have
come up to me after shows that have
either been in contact with you or have
been in contact with other doctors
because of the information that you've
given out.
And it was so thankful and so,
and they're like,
you changing peoples future,
you're literally giving them an option
that they didn't know existed.
They thought they thought their world
was black and then you open the door and
like,
oh,
you can be okay.
When Andrew first came to be,
uh,
Andrew wasn't the first veteran that I
had seen.
The first guy that I took care of was in
2009 he was active greenbrae and in
North Carolina at Bragg and his wife,
I knew she was emergency room doc and
she called me up and told me about her
husband getting ready to get a less than
honorable discharge after four or five
tours of duty in Afghanistan.
And uh,
she explained it to me.
I said,
let me send you a kit.
So I sent a kid out and we got the
results back.
I told her what to do,
she put them on to treatment.
He lasted another two sign up towards or
two towards the duty and was doing
phenomenally well.
But the key that drives me on this is
guys getting back into life,
going to pepperdine business school.
Now a guy who was,
um,
attempted school five times and the
fifth time he was on our protocol for
two or three months,
he ends up getting honors and now he
wants to go back and give back to the va
for them not having treated him
optimally by going into sociology to try
and help them to understand what he had
gone through with us.
We have guys who are in Wall Street now
and
all over,
I mean I'm a Harvard business school.
I mean just all kinds of very
prestigious thing.
They've got their family back there re
calling their parents going on for a
couple of years.
We didn't give them a self help book.
We didn't give him any snow,
Churchill teachings,
anything else,
just fix what was deficient.
Right.
And they were able to come back and make
their own their own choices.
They get their life back on track is
such a giant factor in this whole
equation that people need to understand.
It's not just about motivational
speeches.
It's not about memes that you put on
your instagram page to make you feel
better about life.
It's literally about the chemical
balance in your physical vehicle.
And if it's off,
you're going to be off.
And if it's off because of diet,
if it's off because of injury,
whatever the factors are,
you've got to figure out what those
factors are and you've got to correct
them.
You got to correct them before
self-help,
before all that bullshit,
correct your diet,
correct.
Whatever is deficient in your hormone
levels,
whatever is deficient in your nutrient
levels.
It's so God damn it.
Absolutely.
And I don't mean to,
you know,
focus only on the neuro steroid and the
inflammation,
as you just said,
physical fitness and nutrition.
You know,
my daughter Alison is a natural pathic
and she works with us with the warrior
Angel Foundation to help with getting
the gut brain in sync so that you don't
have the glutens,
you don't have all the junk we talked
about because it,
they generate the poor nutrition,
generates more inflammation that passes
through the gut into the blood,
into the brain.
And they've actually,
there was a study that came out of,
it was on the bbcs last week where they
were talking about,
oh,
we finally figured out that if you have
peripheral inflammation like diseases
like Lupus or rheumatoid arthritis,
that the inflammation goes into the
brain and can cause depression.
Well,
it's been in the literature for 30
years.
They finally are starting to understand
that things that happened on the
periphery,
you can affect our brain's functioning.
So nutrition very important
is part of what's going on to just the
the human bodies.
So insanely complex and there's so much
to understand and so much to be you have
to kind of be like you are,
you have to be obsessed with all this
stuff.
I didn't think I was obsessed.
You're obsessed by pull out my phone up
to your face a little bit more,
but you're you,
what you are doing though is just,
it's,
it's so important and so it,
there's just so little of it out there
for people.
This is part of the problem.
It's like you have to really go looking
for these solutions.
I mean,
you got to go through every door in
every channel and try to find out.
And so many times they want to offer you
some sort of a pill,
some sort of a pharmaceutical drug.
It's some sort of an antidepressant
antianxiety medication.
And if that one doesn't take,
they give you an antianxiety medication
on top of the anti anxiety medication,
fuck,
uh,
lunch or dinner with the admiral in,
Virginia Beach,
the beginning of this year.
And one of the stories that he was
sharing was fact that his wife,
uh,
was diagnosed at a va as having a
thyroid related issues.
So they started treating it in the
course of treating it,
she felt worse because they weren't
giving her the ample amount of
replacement hormones.
So the next thing that the doctor offers
her as an antidepressant,
saying the reason why you still not
feeling well,
it's because the antidepressant.
And when we got to her and checked out
or hormone levels,
her hormone levels were off.
And did they even check her hormone
levels?
No,
of course not.
You know,
they hand those Goddamn antidepressants
out like fucking candy.
That's what was crazy with me.
So I was like,
there's gotta be an underlying
condition.
Like in summary,
tell me what that is.
I know we've got,
we're managing symptoms,
but can we do that and can we do it
objectively or scientifically?
And that's the beauty of,
of of the protocol.
Because again,
to break it down for everybody out
there,
Tbi,
it's a two phase injury phase one is
that a physical trauma or assault?
You know,
it could be black,
uh,
explosive blast way,
blunt force,
trauma acceleration,
deacceleration slip,
fall rollercoaster.
Anything that causes that anti
inflammatory cascade to start
rollercoaster can cause it.
The coordinator Mario Cannon,
the literature.
Yeah,
but just think man,
like,
so mark calls it the neuro permissive
environment.
So if you don't have a good internal
environment,
like you're eating a bunch of processed
foods,
sugar,
you're leaving just a,
a low quality of life,
making poor lifestyle decisions.
Those things,
how are like compounding interest over
time,
uh,
are being like low level blast waves.
And it could be something as simple as
one of those 300 mile per hour moving
roller coaster.
It's going to rock your head back and
forth.
That could be enough to be,
you know,
hey,
that's enough.
That could cause the inflammation and
the inflammatory cascade and then that
causes the hormones to become deficient
or insufficient.
That's what we found through our
research,
at least our,
that's what our research suggests is
that's the process.
And if you don't get rid of the
inflammation or bring the body back into
a balance,
if you don't replenish or replace those
hormones that are lost,
you're going to have all the physical
and psychological manifestations that we
all know about and talked about.
And so that's the deal.
Can we be objective?
Yes,
we can.
Can we measure it?
Yes,
we can.
Can we predict and replicate?
Well,
we've done it 1400 times so we can,
so now it's like,
okay,
well how do we continue to take this to
the next level to make sure this goes
mainstream?
It's disseminating information on
platforms like this.
We're working projects with the
government.
Like right now.
We think we might be able to actually
affect change on a real level here the
next few years.
Yeah,
it's,
it's so incredible
that there is finally some sort of a
resource that there's something that
people could turn to,
but uh,
we need to lay it out.
Like there's,
it's gotta be every point,
right?
It's gotta be nutrition.
It's got to be exercise.
It's got to be reducing the
inflammation.
It's gotta be replacing the hormones,
all those things together.
When,
when,
uh,
an individual is suffering with
symptoms,
I call it symptomatic Tbi.
I don't really agree with the term pts
or ptsd or ptss especially
when there's a history of trauma,
trauma,
trauma to the body or trauma to the
brain.
Yeah.
It's not necessarily,
I think people think of it as like
stressful situations that guys have been
through.
And one of the things that I've found in
talking to a lot of guys who are
operators is they don't have like a high
stress level because of what they've
seen.
Like there,
the,
there were the actors,
they were the ones who are doing the
things.
There weren't,
there's a lot of,
the stress level comes from a lot of the
guys that we're not being proactive.
They're waiting around for something to
happen to them.
And those are the guys that are the most
effected by Stress Disorders.
The guys who were wondering when they
were going to be attacked.
Whereas guys who are operators who are
out there aggressive out there being
proactive actually correct doing it.
They had less of a situation with that.
Less stress meditation for them going
out and killing people.
You're on the offensive,
right?
Yeah.
So I mean I can speak from experience
here.
You're,
you're on the offensive.
You're not waiting to get on there.
So when you're stuck in this,
what it is is a fight or flight
mechanism,
you know what I mean?
You're on security mode,
uh,
in a non combat environment.
And so these guys get stuck in these
fight or flight modes and they can't
figure out why,
why am I in fight or flight like this?
This situation does not call for that
type of response.
And then you look at it like if you're
deficient in these things,
what's the body going to do if these got
these mics,
electrical signals or they're sharing of
neurons,
it's going to come out as a fight or
flight mechanism and that's why they're
stuck in this and that's,
it's called post traumatic stress.
But when we've treat these so called
psychological issues as a physical
injury and replace and replenish,
lower the inflammatory cascades,
guess what?
Those symptoms resolve themselves
whether they were,
whether they were on the defensive or
offensive.
You know what I mean?
That's fascinating.
But there's definitely a psychological
difference between someone who becomes a
seal or a ranger or a green baret there.
There's a documented yes,
there's a,
there's a difference in the mindset and
you know those,
those people are some of the most
important people we have in the planet.
Correct.
You have to have them.
You want to have a safe world.
You have to have the elite of the elite.
You have to like and people who don't
understand that you need to go to some
really terrible places in the world and
understand what's out there.
You know,
looking across the spectrum of special
ops and then the regular army.
We've talked about this in the past.
The pattern that I've been seeing also
in in civilian population is those
people who are more eight type get
better,
faster.
They want to get better as opposed to
the people who really don't want to get,
or you've seen it time and time again.
It's like if you have a clear vision of
the future and it's like,
Hey,
I'm going to get better.
Like I don't care what anybody else
says.
Like they were like the 10th stop that
they've come to their like,
we've tried everything,
we just found a,
you guys were going to do something,
let's get this going.
But those guys get better.
Not,
I mean,
not to mention,
of course,
objectively we can,
we can
push look at it,
but people come to us and you're like,
ah,
I don't know.
Life doesn't work out and everything
goes my way.
You know?
I hope this goes,
but I'm not getting my hopes up.
Anything else?
Those people will talk themselves out of
getting better and I wouldn't have
believed it unless I've seen it time and
time and time again,
hills people mentally fucked themselves
out of life.
Every step of the show we've watched him
put a gun in their mouth and pull the
trigger,
you know what I mean?
Unfortunately we've lost people to do in
that and it wasn't like,
hey,
we got,
we got you the help.
And then it was like,
well it's such a hassle to take the
medication at the prescribed times.
And I'm like,
what?
What?
And then I looked into that and like
that's a thing called noncompliance.
Like,
uh,
the Glaucoma Research Institute put out
a study like 60% of glaucoma patients
don't take their medication on time.
No one that that will cause them to go
blind.
Because I had needed to,
I needed to justify losing some people
that I couldn't,
I couldn't wrap my head around and like,
why won't they be compliant?
They people get in this Rut and they
memorize these emotions and they get in
this negative fucking place,
man.
And they,
they talk themselves right out of life.
And why people become super comfortable
with repeating these really negative
patterns.
They get comfortable because they know
those patterns.
It's very disturbing when you see
someone who's,
you know,
I grew up with a lot of guys that had
drug problems and when you would see
they would get hooked on coke or
something like that and get off of it
and know that they're on a better path,
but it's pulling them back in and not
even physically like the,
the,
the process of doing something that's
fucked up and ruining your life somehow
or another,
it becomes more comfortable than the
process of the unknown,
which is improving your life.
It's,
it's scary to people,
to people they know the of the devil.
They don't,
you know what I mean?
And I think at a neuroscience level,
right?
They could memorize an emotion cause
what I those thoughts and freaky.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whoa re structure of the brain through
neuroplasticity.
And that can be their new status quo.
Right.
How do you get people that are in that
mindset?
How do you get them free of that?
I mean,
how do you get someone who's this woe is
me.
It never works out,
you know?
Is there a way,
I mean,
is there a tried and true way,
man,
to direct my health,
trying to,
I wrecked my health tourism,
but we've had a couple of guys who had
stopped their protocol because they
didn't feel that anything was happening
from it and they send me an email after
they had been off for maybe a month.
I says,
Jeez,
I don't feel as well,
maybe it was working or they say that
we're working with the devil and and go
all kinds of weird.
Yeah.
I stopped January accepting a Pi cases,
you know,
legal cases because what's the impetus
for them to get better?
Yeah,
zero.
They get what they want to pitch a
personal injury,
like the motor vehicle accident there.
One disability check.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so I stopped taking Pi cases.
That's unfortunate because there's gotta
be some
people that have real personal injuries
that would like to get better.
I talked to everybody,
I filter them,
but generally speaking,
I've cut down,
I just come to the conclusion,
you know,
like,
Hey,
I can't make the decision.
I can't make anybody get better.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like all we can do is give out the
information,
but I mean shoes on and make them go to
like literally made myself sick,
like worried about people like,
oh my God,
you know,
we're going to lose something and I
can't like,
man,
I can't do anything.
All I can do is I can control my
attitude and my effort and I can push
out this information to the best of my
ability and people got to meet us
halfway.
You know what I mean?
Like there's nothing we can do to make
somebody want to get themselves better.
Talking with the guy tomorrow is his
brother's at wit's end and just wrecking
everything that he comes in and out of
every rehab program.
Uh,
just as a,
it's a horrible place.
It's,
it's,
I don't see an end in well,
and I'm going to talk to him tomorrow
because he wants to know how can I make
my brother want to get better?
And I'm like,
brother,
I love you man,
but we can't do,
I can't force somebody to do that and
that disaster,
I don't know.
The tragic part of that I think is,
um,
you know,
the person's not thinking right because
they're,
their judgments clouded because of a
head injury.
You know,
serving the country.
It's,
it's,
it's a bummer.
One of the battles that we have also is
that people,
relationships,
I speak to wipes that are a strange
husbands that are strange when we take
on a new veteran or patient,
uh,
to let them know that the person that
they've been dealing with post traumatic
brain injury is not really the person
they want to be.
That's an effect of the hormonal
dysfunctioning.
So they're depressed,
they're angry,
they're,
you know,
they're difficult to be around.
So I tried to get them to help in the
protocol to get them better in what
we've seen are couples getting back
together.
We have a 77 year old,
a Vietnam veteran who lost everything.
He's back with his kids now he's out and
back chopping wood and Boston.
You know,
just,
that's the reward that really is the
reward.
But people have to understand that if
that you've had traumatic brain injury,
anticipate within one year's time,
total change in the person,
total change.
They're now no longer the person that
you anticipate.
How long did it take you for that
transition?
Well,
it was,
uh,
I started first having symptoms like six
months after I got home.
You know what I mean?
So that's the difficult part.
Like you're not missing a limb,
so you don't think anything like,
we are rocking and rolling,
come back,
good to go,
happy to be alive.
Let's get ready for the next one.
And then boom,
stuff starts happening and it's like,
oh my gosh,
what's going on?
You know?
Um,
but you can't see anything and you just
keep going and you keep seeing this low
quality of life and then you want help
and you can't get help.
Uh,
you asked for help,
you're getting medication,
start drinking,
sleep gets messed up,
nutrition gets messed up,
start wrecking relationships,
then start thinking about,
I'll never be able to do what I thought
I was supposed to do.
Nobody understands me.
Um,
what's the future gonna be like,
like this,
you know,
and it doesn't get neat.
And that's how you get trapped into
these memorizing these negative states.
Cause you get stuck in that for you.
You heard mark on the podcast,
how long did it take you to act and how
long did it take after their tea for you
to become who you are now?
It's,
so I made that decision at my son's
bedside and that was,
uh,
several months before I met mark.
Well heres this,
how many years ago?
This is 2000,
uh,
14.
January 7th,
September of 2014 and I didn't meet him
until December,
2014.
Right?
So,
uh,
it was all of 2014.
It was just a disaster,
right.
Leading up to the hospital scene.
So I made the decision like,
Hey,
at that point it was like,
you know what?
I've always been defined by my future,
but all of a sudden like,
you know,
like being a special forces greenbrae
was my mask.
We all wear our masks and that's how I,
uh,
that that was my identity,
or at least I thought it was.
And so when that got taken away from me,
it was like,
well,
what am I going to do now?
And now I'm sick and now my children are
sick and now they're telling me like I
have a brain injury.
Like what does that mean?
Like that this is like just getting
rocked.
So like being rocked by circumstances
knocked me for a year and a half,
just,
it knocked me and like I wasn't
prepared,
I wasn't ready.
I didn't know how to deal with it.
And it wasn't until I made that decision
that I was like,
no,
I've always been defined by going after
the future that I want to create.
I'm going back to that.
And it was like,
so there was like a will,
you know,
that was to it.
Like,
I don't know where it came from,
but like I could observe my thoughts and
I was like,
these thoughts that are being produced
now or not me,
I don't know where they're coming from,
but there is a will inside me that says
we're gonna fight this and we're going
to,
we're going to find a way to come out on
the other side.
So that happened in September,
you know,
uh,
fast forward to finding mark.
So it was like quick,
like after three months of the protocol,
like physiologically I felt like myself
again,
I was off all medication every three
miles.
How long did it take you to get off the
medication?
Did you Turkey,
[inaudible] Turkey,
they say,
you should never do that.
Never do that.
I would just have that in place in my
life.
Doctors,
no,
I,
how's that?
A place in my life that I was like,
Hey,
I am,
I accept whatever fallout could happen,
but whatever I'm going to feel it's not
going to be artificial.
I'm just going to feel whatever it is
and I'm a,
and I'm going to deal with it on,
on my terms.
And I'm not going to be zombied out.
It was rough.
Um,
so I,
I was off all medication before I got to
mark,
you know what I mean?
And so,
uh,
I didn't like,
I didn't have control of like my mind
the way I wanted to like the way I do
now.
So it was,
I had to work very hard and not just to
lose it on people.
For instance,
like we were,
um,
my was with my wife,
we were in a fast food restaurant
picking up some food for my youngest
daughter.
And so I'm going there,
grabbing some food.
I see this kid,
teenager in the parking lot and he,
I don't know,
this kid throws his cup down,
he's cussing,
he's causing the scene.
I felt like I needed to intervene.
I don't know why.
So I'm like,
Hey man,
pick your cup up,
throw in the trash,
quit yelling customers everywhere
families are here.
And he tells me to go fuck myself.
And I'm like,
dude,
go pick up your stuff and put in the
trash.
And he said the same thing.
And before I knew it,
I just backhanded this kid across the
face,
dropped them on the ground,
and then I picked him up and I threw him
into oncoming traffic.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
Well the parking lot took offense to
that.
Right?
It's right.
Rightly rightly so.
You know what I mean?
And so I got people swarming me.
Next thing I know,
like I dropped like three dudes in the
parking lot and I look up after dropping
the last guy and like my wife's
breastfeeding and three of my children
are looking at me and like they're in,
they're an like horror is on their face.
Just horror struck.
And I'm like,
my God man,
if I don't get control of myself,
like not only is this going to possibly
kill me,
I'm going to kill somebody else.
You know what I mean?
Like I had,
I felt like I,
I just,
I didn't know what happened.
Something happened.
Boom.
I came to and it was like,
Dear God,
I just dropped a parking lot and I'm
doing evasive maneuvers in my fucking
minivan trying to get out of it.
Oh my God,
I'm funny.
But not,
but not funny.
You know what I mean?
So,
you know,
it was,
it was this process of,
um,
so it was rough man.
It was rough coming off medication.
I don't recommend it from anybody for
anybody else,
but it was like,
hey man,
like I want off of that.
Cause that just made me a Zombie,
just like drooling on myself.
Zone B.
What steps did you take as far as your
diet and exercise and then mark's
protocol?
I eat,
uh,
you know,
basically try to anti inflammatory diet,
you know what I mean?
Um,
and that's just based off my individual
needs at that time.
Um,
I would just remaining active.
So what I mean by anti inflammatory
diet,
what did you do differently?
Uh,
well,
just learning what causes inflammation,
right?
So where are we talking about?
Like refined sugars,
refined carbohydrates,
getting away from things that were
packaged for me,
you know what I mean?
Going back to more wholesome,
whole foods.
And this is before mark's protocol or,
no,
this is,
this is after I'm on it.
You know what I mean?
So I didn't make any changes until I got
up anything until I got into mark's
protocol.
Started to like return to normalcy.
And then when you get to that level,
you start feeling really good again.
You're like,
well,
what else can I do?
You know what I mean?
And that's,
that's like been the steps that we've
seen in so many people.
Like we don't have to make any lifestyle
changes initially,
like thrill make them on their own.
So get them back to a homeostasis or
balance and neuro permissive environment
and mark as mark calls it.
And then you start looking at like,
well,
what else do I need to do in my life to
optimize it?
And for me,
man,
it was like,
I'm going to take a look at water,
I'm going to be taking a look at,
uh,
light,
sound,
emf,
like every external,
you know,
stimulus.
I want to optimize and make sure,
like it's as optimized as possible.
Well,
so,
um,
did you do any changes to the way you
exercise?
Let me think about that.
Not Really,
man.
Uh,
I was kind of into Olympic lifting at
the time and stayed with that.
Um,
uh,
physical,
physically,
always remain physically active through
the whole thing.
Um,
so not a,
probably the only thing that probably
kept you sane.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And another reason they said that I
lived through the,
uh,
the blood clots was the level of
cardiovascular fitness that I was in at
the time.
You know what I mean?
So,
uh,
yeah.
But yeah,
that was like,
you know,
one Goto,
like I just always worked out.
I've always been,
that's always been a part of my life.
And so that was always there.
So stuck with that.
So three months in,
how did you feel and what was the
difference?
I felt night and day different.
No more anxiety,
no more depression.
No more balance issues.
No more double vision.
No more blurry vision.
No more migraine headaches.
Uh,
no more memory problems.
Like back on,
like I could go back to operating and
you know what I mean?
And Oh,
hey,
33 disability according to the va
hundred percent service-related disabled
is what?
33?
What were they?
Oh Gosh,
dude.
Like I named them like uh,
everything,
every kind of psychological disorder
that you could think of,
like double digit like I was given,
you know what I mean?
Depressed,
anxiety,
insomnia,
so like psychotic.
Yeah,
just all,
all these different things and then just
a whole host of physical injuries as
well that they've been documented over
time,
but they're just like 33 disabilities,
100% disabled.
I don't,
I'm not missing a beat man.
I'm not in any chronic pain.
I don't have any symptomology of any of
those things and we've that's not
specific or special to me.
Right.
Like mark,
how can we've been able to take so many
dudes come off of their pain medication
without going into withdrawals like we
need.
You need to talk about that.
That's crazy.
Matthew was here.
Matthew was on 16 medications.
One of the medications was oxycontin.
He was on 80 milligrams a day.
He was a morphine sulfate,
240 milligrams a day.
He was on fentanyl patches and in six
weeks,
no patches.
Fentanyl patches on top of it.
Every anesthesiologists that I run by
with what he was on,
said the guy shouldn't be walking.
Well,
he flew down from,
from Washington to come his tolerance,
it must've just been off the charts
tolerance stuff,
tolerance and you know,
he had six pins in his draw,
shrapnel out of the left side of his
head and his right leg was shot.
And um,
that's the reason why they justify it
all his medications six weeks after
starting the protocol,
unique for him based on the biomarkers.
He was on two medications a year later,
he's off all his medications and he
moves to Hollywood to become an actor
and a screenwriter.
Totally function,
no pain.
We're going to fuck him up more than
anything else to go back on 17
medications,
right?
No,
but the question was,
I started seeing this pattern as andrew
brought up,
we're guys,
we're getting offered their medications
and no withdrawal.
So I went back to the literature and
started seeing the things about Nibin
all a and b receptors,
the more the opioid receptor alpha and
Beta the mu receptors.
And it turns out a lot of the things
that we do modify it and modulating.
And then more recently talking about
pregnenolone,
which is that mother of all hormones
that comes off of cholesterol,
where they're using it in people who are
addicted to Benzodiazepines,
which are,
you know,
valium and so forth,
where they have side effects from being
on such a high dose where they're
sleeping all the time.
They give him pregnenolone and it
decreases their fatigued during the day.
And it turns out that we're value more
benzodiazepines work on this thing
called the Gaba a receptor,
which is one of those relay stations.
Um,
pregnenolone is what is what should be
given instead of giving someone a
benzodiazepine.
So that's how we've been able to get all
our people off of antianxiety medication
has with this pregnenolone because of
how it functions and it's all out there.
I didn't invent anything.
It's just reading the literature.
That's incredible.
I love Brie.
So it fits into the same cell receptors,
the same receptor called the
benzodiazepine receptor on the Gabba a
that's crazy,
man.
Yeah.
You've seen dudes that were,
I didn't know what we were going to do.
And like they're,
I'm pain free,
no pain,
none.
And coming,
not coming off the meds with without
withdrawals.
Critics.
Were you,
did they put you on tramadol or,
yeah,
a man,
I don't even remember,
but it was,
it was a long time ago because he had
been off of it.
What are the things that disturbs me the
most about this is what if someone like
you wasn't around,
like what you're,
you're kind of an outlier in the medical
community that you've really gravitated
towards helping soldiers,
helping people with Tbi for athletes,
football players,
fighters.
What if you weren't around?
I mean,
I,
I'm not hearing about this from a lot of
guys.
Well,
Andrew and I,
uh,
in 2015 when my second third book came
out on traumatic brain injury,
when we started giving classes,
very inexpensive classes for docs to
come in and get trained.
So to date,
we've trained specifically on the
technology,
about 400 docs and they're going through
a process of training and exams and so
forth before they become part of our
network.
It's wire Angel Foundation Network,
uh,
so that we can disseminate the
information and have more people
involved.
But this is such an important thing and
it's such a common factor.
There's so many people that are
suffering from depression and anxiety
and all these different issues that very
easily could be attached,
traumatic brain injuries
and,
and people that don't even think they've
had traumatic brain juice,
sub concussive trauma.
There's,
there's a lot of people that have just
done,
they just been had a knock,
knock and tumble rough and tumble life
and then I'll realize it,
but they've caused damage to their
brain.
We see,
we have patients who come in under our
wellness program and when they're asked,
have you ever had any traumatic brain
injury?
They say no,
but you look at the bio markers and you
see the pattern that they've had head
trauma and then they say,
oh yeah,
when I was 18 there,
you know,
53 years of age or 47 years of age.
Oh yeah.
When I was 18,
I was in a car accident and I hit my
left side of my head against the,
uh,
driver's side window.
I did not,
wasn't knocked out,
didn't have nausea,
didn't have vomiting.
And you think because of that,
that you're immune.
Well,
it turns out that 85% of all traumatic
brain injuries are called mild for a
reason.
You don't have any symptoms.
Yeah.
Some people might have a little bit of a
headache,
uh,
you know,
or feeling fatigued.
But for the most part they feel nothing.
And then there's 15% that make up the
moderate to severe where they're in a
coma for periods of time.
And we've actually had people who were
in coma,
some of our vets who have been in coma
told,
uh,
connors,
who was told that,
uh,
he'll never walk.
He'll never be able to,
you know,
take care of himself.
He'll die young and so forth.
The Guy,
he's married and he's walking,
he's bicycle riding on,
on,
what is it?
Facebook.
He shows his pictures and so forth that,
listen,
this guy couldn't walk.
They told him he wouldn't walk again.
We've got three guys like that.
And what was,
what were they saying?
They want the,
uh,
the imaging,
right mark and still shows damage in the
what?
The gray matter.
Oh,
are the white matter and the white
matter.
But he's made new connections and so now
that's why he's able to do it because of
the protocols allowed him to go back
into this neuro permissive environment.
So what does that mean?
That means that he can experience new
things.
The brain is rewiring itself,
even though there's physical damage to
certain lobes because he can rewire
itself,
he can get better and he's walking.
We have got three guys like that.
It's crazy.
All the hormones that we talk about,
the testosterone,
estrogen,
progesterone,
we relate to them as gender hormones,
male or female.
We reproductive hormones,
sex hormones.
It turns out that each one of them has a
secondary function to Stastrom,
stimulates the immune system to increase
the white blood cells,
the CD four and cd eight which are the
protective kind of white blood cells.
It also decreases the inflammation in
our body called the t h one section of
the immune system and stimulates the
anti-inflammatory,
Estradiol,
progesterone,
pregnenolone,
now pregnenolone.
They all function to improve Alzheimer's
conditions.
So if you're an elderly male or female
with low levels of hormones and you're
starting to develop dementia,
you need to have your hormones looked at
because they regulate all these things
and to document it up the Kazoo or was,
what about the interpretation?
That's,
that's also where your unconventional
kariah standard means.
We've,
I've looked at it from uh,
a shift,
you know,
hormone x,
whatever it is,
has a range of 10 to 90 so you go to
your doctor and you get the blood tests
and it's 15 and you've got all the
symptoms as though you're at below 10
and the doctor says you shouldn't be
having any symptoms because you're
within that range that we called the
reference range.
But it turns out that not all of us are
identical genetically and function very
well at that specific level of 15.
So what we do is we bring people up to
what's called the median 10 on the
bottom 90 on the top,
yet it together you get a hundred you
divided by two and that's the
statistical median.
So we move people from that 15 all the
way up towards that 50 and some people
hit 20 and say,
Geez,
I feel better.
25 29.
And then there's a population who have
had the greatest amount of head trauma,
traumatic brain injury where they need
to go up between 50 and 75% and we still
keep everybody within the normal
physiological range as predict them by a
traditional medicine,
classical medicine.
And that's where we get the benefits.
And that's the reason why,
um,
a lot of these guys have had a missed
opportunity by their primary care doc to
improve them is because they are still
functioning under the old paradigm,
which in 1975 to major biostatisticians
came out with these two books that are
like eight pounds each.
And all they talked about is how all
this science,
all this chemistry that we do for people
that it doesn't apply to you.
And I,
it applied to the people that were part
of that study to set the standard range
or the reference range because I wasn't
part of that group.
So my,
what's normal for me wasn't part of
that.
So what the guy said was the two guys
said was what's best is to develop your
own reference range based on your body.
And he should do the same as I've been
doing over the past 60 years.
So a guy comes in and he's an 11 and
they tell him what he's normal in this
hypothetical situation,
he still has,
has all these symptoms,
right?
So what we do in a provocative to
stossel testing and the guy and I also
do it in females,
is we test the theory out,
okay,
if it is the case,
I'm going to give you a shot.
What did you say you felt like for 60
hours since Cinderella?
Cinderella.
I got three daughters,
so I know,
I know that Disney well,
okay,
fine.
So he received his injection and he
drove on the full of five talk to Becky
for an hour and she told me the story,
like she was in amazement that it goes
that guy.
Yeah,
totally.
He didn't think it was me.
That was good.
So,
but anyway,
he sends back a,
what happens is after they get their
injection,
they send back five days later,
this questionnaire that says how well
they did.
And in big letters in the area,
that's for comments,
he says,
I felt Cinderella
after the ball and for 60 hours he was
just cruising.
And we're using physiological dosing of
testosterone.
I don't believe in,
you know,
everybody who comes to the office is not
abiding bodybuilder.
So we give physiological dosing because
if you give it more consistently,
they get a better response.
So he was given 60 milligrams of a
blended testosterone,
had a phenomenal,
you had a good response,
you could respond.
But the crazy thing is we're talking
about from 2014 we're in 2017 almost
2018 now,
where,
I mean we're less than four years and
all this change has happened.
Correct.
That's what's amazing that you've
started the warrior Angels Foundation,
that you have helped so many soldiers
since then that you've gotten the word
out through your foundation.
We're dealing with a very short amount
of time and so many people have been
helped to this amazing extent.
Correct.
And you know we asked people how'd they
hear about us and thank God that we
started back in two 14 on your show.
The first one,
so many people have commented to me,
look at,
if you see Joe would just thank them for
us.
We have lists and lists of people who
would like to thank you for the fact
that you believed in what I was doing
enough to,
to have us on the show the first time
back in 2014 separate Korean man and
people seek,
keep hearing it for the first time like
I ceased to.
It never ceases to amaze me every week I
get just a ton of mail from people who
heard it for the first time that like I
didn't,
I didn't think there was any solution
out there,
man.
Well,
I think this is a really good time to do
this.
Again,
this is one of the reasons why I was
excited about this because the podcast
has grown exponentially since then.
It's so,
it's much,
much,
the,
the audience is much larger now.
So I think we're going to be able to
affect and help a lot more people.
Um,
so for people that are interested,
people that want to find out more
information and then they want to try to
help themselves,
what's the best steps?
Well,
so we set up the organization.
We had such a outpouring because of all
the media,
like it was an overwhelming,
uh,
almost to get to everybody.
So basically what we do now is we grant
a millennium health centers so much
money and we were helped to subsidize
costs like that.
So they'll go with our grants to mark's
a facility.
They'll go there,
they'll fill out information,
uh,
through his website,
which is millennium.
Let's see,
Tbi med,
legal.com.
That's Tbi Med med,
They'll fill out a new patient
information packet,
put in all their information there.
Then they can be seen that way.
And let me tell you this about mark.
Every time I go to visit him for a
doctor's visit,
he won't let me pay.
He may make pay for other soldiers.
That's what he does.
He picks patients out and he goes,
well,
let's pick some guys out.
You're gonna pay for them.
And that's how he does it.
And You have,
they're appreciative.
Absolutely.
What you do as beautiful are the
corporation,
our corporation,
Millennium Health Centers,
inks,
uh,
has a fund.
And what it does is it underwrites a
portion of the veterans.
And then warrior Angel Foundation
underwrites another portion of it.
So,
you know,
revenue that we get from the,
um,
some of the products you sell and so
forth goes to help,
uh,
pay for it.
People have to pay for it,
Joe.
But we found that they need to have some
skin in the game.
Yep.
You know what I mean?
That that enables us to be met halfway.
So again,
we've subsidized the rate where we've
made it.
It's a form,
like it's affordable period.
But now it's really affordable.
Uh,
cause the insurance not taken for a
whole host of different reasons,
but so we've made it that way.
And so now like we used to handle every
case individually,
the warrior Angels Foundation and,
and fund them and,
and it was just a hipaa mess and,
and everything else.
So now we fund them directly and I've
worked to subsidize these rates and make
it affordable so we can help more people
get treatment and
talk about that,
about having skin in the game and how
important that is just psychologically
for people.
It seems like if you give people things
for free,
they just don't appreciate it as much as
you can make them work for it.
It's,
it's unfortunate because there's a lot
of people that really will work hard for
something.
They just don't have the financial
means.
But there's so many that that applies to
that.
If you just give it to them,
they don't appreciate it.
It's too easy.
It comes too easy.
Yeah.
Well fortunately very few people have
responded that way.
The vets have been really good.
They've heard about us from either your
show or from one of the shows or from
their colleagues who are in the program
and they see how well it is.
And they look at the how dismal their
life is,
right?
And they have a choice.
Make a choice.
You want to live the life that Andrew
had in the past or the enjoyment and the
love of life that he has now.
And how could someone like me donate?
Oh,
it's on our website.
Waf,
tbi.org.
It's a,
we're a five zero one c three,
so it's tax deductible and you can go in
there on top right is the uh,
donate.
Um,
we have a film coming out called quiet
explosions,
uh,
top.
There you go.
That uh,
that's our trailer right there.
Uh,
so we've got an emmy award winning
director.
Here it is.
Can you play that Jamie?
Go full screen.
The average of glass,
we have travels at 163 miles per hour.
It says
that's a great pick.
You got to see this video folks and
people that are just listening to the
podcast.
You've got to see the impact of these
blasts.
Explosive.
So any type of injury that we needed to
get into a place that was denied for
whatever reason,
be it a door or whatever,
I was the guy who would place those
charges to get us in.
You're not the person that you used to
be.
I can't remember things home.
I don't
know where I'm at.
Five years.
I've driven that route everyday.
All of a sudden look up.
You don't know where you're at.
I said to myself,
you know,
this is going to go one of two ways.
I continue on this path and it's going
to kill me.
Or I can make a decision to quit blaming
my circumstance and decide to act.
And it says in 2014 when you met Mark
Gordon,
hormone deficiency and suicide are
connected
for the people listening to something
you need to see.
It's just a lot of the text on the page
talking about the benefits of this and
how much it's helped.
Andrew and
what does the name of this video,
Jamie?
So people get
quiet explosions and we just started
production this month,
right mark?
Yeah,
correct.
This month.
And so,
uh,
if you want to donate to that,
you can donate there.
That'll also be a tax deductible in this
is a donation three that you guys are
doing.
And what do you mean?
We're going to do three,
uh,
three different stories.
All people through the foundation.
So we have two other crew,
incredible stories.
And then the top minds in a,
in science,
in neuroendocrinology and neuroscience
neuropathology are talking about
traumatic brain injury and the protocol.
So it's kind of a concussion,
you know what I mean?
Identified a problem.
We're identifying a solution.
So not only are we bringing out for the
first time ever,
you know,
what is the real underlying condition
behind traumatic brain injury.
Here's a solution,
here's all the science behind it,
here's the specialists in their field
confirming,
you know,
what the literature has been saying.
And so we hope to bring that out in
2019.
And what are you going to do with it
when you bring it out?
We're just disseminate the information.
Are you going to release it online?
You're going to release it in movie
theaters?
Yes.
Yeah.
All of that.
As many places you can.
Absolutely.
I'm not sure how it's gonna all be
distributed.
The goal right now is to disseminate the
information.
That's it.
As we have more potential individuals
who are suffering,
listening to this,
uh,
we've been training doctors,
we've been getting through multiple
avenues through the military,
through the different,
uh,
divisions.
Um,
getting them on board,
supporting US Navy Seal Foundation has
supported us.
Um,
that's all we're trying to do and we've
got enough ground swell in our
population to justify it.
As Andrew has said,
multiple times,
it's reproducible,
predictable,
and there's something that I want to
impart here.
There's a stigma with men in particular
in this country when it comes to
hormones and replacing hormones.
Um,
they're very embarrassed by it.
They don't like it.
It disturbs them.
Um,
and they start to think of it as
cheating or they start to think of it as
steroids.
They look at it in
an illogical way and that illogical ways
connected to,
I think in my opinion,
the stigmas in our culture that are
attached to performance enhancing drugs,
like for cheating in sports in the
Olympics.
And you always hear about them in this
sort of negative way.
So there's a lot of guys that they shy
away.
I've talked to many friends who are very
smart and they,
they talked to me about testosterone.
I'm like,
dude,
I've been on testosterone for 10 years
and make it changes your life.
It changes,
it changes the way you function.
I'm 50 years old,
my body functions like it did when I was
30 and that's a fact.
It really does.
And I pushed that motherfucker all the
time.
So I'm not,
I'm not telling you this from just a
theoretical standpoint.
I'm talking about from the physical
action perspective.
And I tell this to people and you see it
go in one ear and out the other.
I don't want to take any testosterone.
I don't want to,
I don't want to go to a doctor that's
gonna get me human growth hormone.
I don't want to look at my hormone
levels and like,
but you're,
you're depressed and you're tired all
the time and you're,
you're trying all these different
things.
You're taking Zoloft,
you're getting magnet therapy.
I know people who've gotten ketamine
shots and all these different things to
try to cure depression.
I'm like,
why don't you look at your fucking
hormones,
man?
Yeah.
They can look at,
it doesn't mandate that they have to
take it,
but they should know.
They should know.
Absolutely.
But what mark's talking about is your
physiological optimal level.
Right?
And so that hypothetical scenario that
he gave earlier,
if you're out at an 11 you know what I
mean?
And you're just once you know,
point above normal.
Well guess what?
That's not normal.
You know what I mean?
You're on the perceived lower end.
So he has a completely different sliding
scale to measure that.
But to me it would like be taken
objective analysis and just get a
snapshot of where that's at and like
maybe to see what it would be like to
push it up a little bit and see if life
improved.
Not,
it's super physiological,
physiological based on you in normal
healthy levels.
Yeah,
you might,
you might find out that,
hey man,
I went up,
you know,
10 points and I'm great,
or you had to push it really high.
You're different,
you know,
different strokes for different folks,
but I'm trying to figure out is why
would someone rather take a psychotropic
medication than fixing what God has
given our body to manufacture that
because of trauma,
because of genetics or whatever.
You're not producing it at the level.
And another fallacy for me,
a fallacy is that as we get older,
it's acceptable to have lower and lower
levels of hormones.
Well,
how about this?
The reason why they're getting lower and
lower is because of the shitty food
you're eating.
The fact that you had 60 years of
traumatic brain injury,
which have interrupted the brain's
ability to regulate homeostasis,
to regulate your hormone production.
That's the reason why the levels are
lower.
So bringing it back to 25 to 35 years of
age,
which has been the dictum in our office
for the past 27 years has been key.
Yeah.
One of the things that jumped my
testosterone up a bunch is cutting out
processed carbohydrates.
All the refined carbohydrates.
It just jumped it like 50% it was like
it doubled it and I was like,
this is insane.
Right?
So it tells you how important the
biochemistry is of the buddy of the body
to regulate other aspects of it.
Yeah,
and the Diet and exercise and sleep and
all these different factors.
But when I saw that my,
my testosterone,
it bumped up and then ultimately
doubled.
I,
I was so confused as to why it took me
so long to figure this out,
that eating pasta and bread and pizza
and all the bullshit was having an
effect not just on like body fat,
but it's having an effect on your whole
body being able to process all of these
chemicals.
You got to think of yourself as a
machine and people don't like to do
that.
But think of your body as a machine.
If you have a machine or an engine or
any,
or can think of it as a vehicle,
you're,
you've got to have,
yeah,
you need spark plugs.
You need cooling,
you need gasoline,
you need all these different factors and
if you don't have the proper amount of
engine oil,
if you don't have the spark plugs aren't
working right,
the vehicle is not going to work right.
Your body is far more complex than a
car,
but similar in that respect.
The an analogy I like car analogies.
Uh,
you've got a brand new porsche nine 11
carrera with four flat tires.
Choose one of them to fill up and drive.
You're not going to be able to before
cardinal harm hormones of our body and I
see colleagues of mine who only focus in
on one hormone.
How are you going to be able to have a
nice level ride if you don't look at all
for the key hormones and the also the
insanely complex way that all these
different nutrient levels and hormone
levels interact with each other and that
they're all a part of this incredible
system that takes forever to just
scratch the surface of understanding.
I mean I read a lot,
I've just scratched the surface of
understanding what's going on and I'm
not sure I understand it.
It is so complex,
but when you see the results,
you know that at least you're down the
right pathway.
It's a symphony,
you know,
that's what they always say it's a
symphony.
But how better did you feel,
you know,
after cutting out those things and your
testosterone better,
right?
Like almost immediately like the big one
was the not needing a nap.
Yeah.
You know,
like in the middle of the day I just
assumed that I would get up,
I would eat breakfast.
Then around three I'd be like,
fuck,
I need to crash.
It's testosterone deficiency.
Three o'clock does that.
And then there's also the insulin pump
right from the shitty process foods and
carbohydrates.
I came off all protocols that 2017 for
seven months for this year.
Cause just because I wanted to see what
would happen.
One I thought like the brain and body
went back to Nerpa miss of environment
and the hypothalamus and my pituitary
gland would turn back on.
But it wasn't the case.
We had two labs to followed up.
But I had to prove to myself,
I guess emotionally,
spiritually
that I,
you know,
I could slay that dragon and I could
live life without it.
But it wasn't,
it was no by no means of the imagination
optimized.
You know what I mean?
And then when I went back on it,
man,
like my body composition changed again
and I noticed increased energy and I
thought I was doing well,
but I was like,
life is better.
I'm a better person when this is
optimized.
And so,
you know,
I've proven to myself that I can do it
without it,
but life is not better.
I mean we use of it.
We might be looking at some time in the
near future where they can do something
genetically where they can alter the way
your pituitary gland functions are.
Some of the different things with
Crispr,
with many of these genetic manipulation
tools that they're working on right now.
But as of right now,
that's not the case.
No,
you have to get tested and then
replenish back to physiological levels.
All the hormones,
not a select all of them actually just
do one.
You can mess up the whole,
the whole thing.
Right.
Is there a network of doctors that
you've trained that you trust their work
that you can recommend?
Is there a way that people,
so they don't have to travel to
California to meet you?
Right.
Uh,
on the website,
um,
there's uh,
give that website out again,
a Tbi Med,
legal tb,
I m e d l e g a l.
Dot com has,
uh,
under Tbi network and training.
It has a list of doctors.
We've trained doctors in Spain,
United States,
Canada,
New Zealand,
Australia.
I'm going to Southeast Asia to train a
group,
uh,
in Cambodia and Vietnam for a project,
which is to establish centers in
Southeast Asia because there's a lot of
retired vets there.
Pull it up again,
Jamie.
A lot of retired vets to set up centers
so they can offer treatment.
And if you look at the website,
it's listed all in alphabetical order.
We have California,
there's Arizona there,
Colorado,
Florida,
there's,
my name's on it are people who are in
the process of getting their
certification.
So there's a four hour exam they have to
take and pass it with the least 70% and
then present two cases showing they have
the ability to uh,
utilize the information.
So there's doctors available in many,
many states and that's been our goal to
make this network of doctors where you
can reach people at scale in the same
way like train trainers are trained
doctors and that's what we're working on
with the government right now.
What's incredible is it how much you've
accomplished in such a short period of
time?
That's what's really incredible.
Obsessed.
Yes.
It driven,
totally driven better.
Uh,
there's nothing wrong in obsessed.
I'm obsessed with everything.
People have a hard time with that word.
They think it's like it's gotten away
from them.
Passionate.
Passionate is good.
I liked that as we're taking the action,
but like for the right reasons and like
opportunities just continues to present
itself.
I think that's just the byproduct of a
right way of doing things.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
let's be proactive.
Let's go there.
Let's make things happen.
Yeah,
let's go do it.
He said to me in the beginning,
he said,
we're going to be doing the right things
for the right reason.
And what'll happen is things will shake
out of the trees and land in front of
us.
And that's what basically has been
happening.
We just,
you know,
money.
It's not the issue.
Just get the work done in the response
and the reaction of our vets.
Well,
the reaction,
the response has been incredible as far
as like what I've heard and what,
what's come to me about it.
And uh,
hopefully we're shaking that fucking
Shit,
man.
Yeah.
Dude,
because of this show,
because of you,
like this information has been widely
disseminated man.
And uh,
you helped promote our book and give us
a blurb for that.
So thank you for that.
A tales from the blast factory,
uh,
supports what we're doing.
Uh,
that comes out next month if anybody's
interested in,
in that,
matter of fact,
we did a thing on Amazon,
Joe,
or they get it for 99 cents.
So we want people to get that book.
Wow.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
All right.
So,
uh,
any closing thoughts that we need to get
out there,
if these people,
then we covered it all.
I think we covered it all.
Um,
you know,
my last closing statement is,
thank you so much.
Listen,
thank you.
I'm,
I'm forever in your debt and I think
that what you guys are both doing is
incredible and I'm honored that I could
play a small part in getting this out
there.
It's just,
it means,
it means everything.
Thank you.
Thank you for the butter.
My heart.
All right,
fuckers.
That's it for the day.
We'll see you tomorrow,
but by
donate.